thoughts on the kobe shack dynamic and
kind of what it's like
going through a game like today with a d
um especially at a similar level of
efficiency
um you know obviously being in high
school and watching the kobe shack
do duo it was the most dominant duo that
i have personally seen in my life from a
basketball perspective
um i hadn't seen uh uh obviously you we
knew the force
that uh shaq brought to the table but
the elegance and force that kobe played
with as well
they were very dominant in what they did
on the floor on both sides of the floor
so to be in a conversation with those
two guys
myself and anthony myself and a.d he
would
he's going to kill me um myself and a.d
um it's just very humbling because uh i
mean i know i grew up watching those
guys
i grew up with myron kobe obviously for
you know a kid coming straight out of
high school so
you know admired that kid that was young
and got the opportunity and
and obviously the force that shaq played
with so i'm just just very humbling and
i'm happy that we we can be even
mentioned with those greats
you